revue des troupes pour le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner et son
secrétaire d'état laurent nunez ses
fonctionnaires font partie d'un corps
spécialisé de la police nationale les
crs
tous les ans la direction zonale des crs
paris basé à vélizy villacoublay
accueille la cérémonie de translation du
drapeau cette année c'est la zone sud
est qui a passé le drapeau à la zone est
christophe castaner on a également
profité pour réaffirmer son soutien aux
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
en première ligne ces dernières semaines
avec le mouvement des gilet jaune
nous avons souhaité être là tous les
deux pour être aux côtés aux côtés des
crs crs qui sont sur le terrain du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre qui sont là pour
protéger les français
j'ai souhaité aussi porter ce message
d'exigence ce message d'exigence
vis-à-vis d'un comportement qui ne doit
rien céder à l'éthique
le ministre de l'intérieur a remis des
médailles pour acte de courage et de
dévouement
avec un budget de la police nationale en
hausse en 2010 9 christophe castaner a
également évoqué des mesures à venir
notamment pour les 600 fonctionnaires de
vélizy on fait partie intégrante du plan
immobilier que nous avons lancé 900
millions d'euros entre 2018 et 2020 et
vous en verrez les effets ici même à
vélizy ou un nouveau cantonnement de
passage devra être créé ces lieux
permettent de mieux recevoir des
compagnies de passage qui seront plus
nombreuses à vélizy pour les jeux
olympiques en 2024